هذا المسدس الصغير
ظهر الزعيم الشيشاني رمضان قاديروف ملوحا
به ومدعيا انه المسدس الذي انتحر به
الزعيم النازي ادولف هتلر قديروف كان يرسل
برساله الى الرئيس الاوكراني
دعاه فيها الى اطلاق النار على نفسه تماما
كما فعل هتلر وبصرف النظر عن الرسائل
والتهديدات بين طرفي نزاع في اوكرانيا لفت
المسدس انظار المتابعين واعاد الجدل حول
حقيقه ما حدث فعلا مع هتلر الروايه الاشهر
والاكثر قبولا لدى المجتمع الدولي هي
انتحار الزعيم النازي عن طريق تناول ماده
السيانيد السامه ثم اطلاق النار على نفسه
بواسطه مسدسه في الثلاثين من ابريل عام
1945 لكن الظروف الغامضه والمحيط بالحادثه
ساعدت على انتشار الشائعات وتكذيب البعض
لروايه الانتحار
الروايات تشير الى ان هتلر تمكن من الهرب
بصحبه زوجته الى الارجنتين وتخفياه هناك
بعد الخضوع لعمليات تجميل وعاشا باسمين
مستعارين وان هتلر عاش ما تبقى من حياته
هناك حتى توفي عام
1962 بحسب الروايه المزعومه على الجانب
الاخر اكدت شهادات المقربين من الزعيم
النازي والذين عايشوا لحظاته الاخيره
روايه انتحاره وابرز تلك الشهادات تعود
لجانس باور الطيار الشخصي لهتلر جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي نشر في ابريل عام
2022 وثائق ارشيفيه جديده لما قال باور
خلال استجوابه في جهاز الامن السوفيتي عام
في الثلاثين من ابريل بعد الظهر اتصل هتلر
وبمساعده استقبلني وقادني الى غرفته
صافحني واعلمني انه يريد ان يقول لي وداعا
وشكرني على كل سنوات الخدمه اصبح هتلر
كبيرا في السن ومرهقا وكانت يداه ترتجفان
وكان واضحا لي انه اتخذ القرار النهائي
بالانتحار
باور قال ان الزعيم النازي امر بحرق جثته
وجثه زوجته لانه كان يخشى ان يتم شنقهما
وتشفي بهما وكانت كلماته الاخيره لطياره
الخاص انه في يوم ما سيتعين عليهم الكتابه
على شاهد قبره انه وقع ضحيه لجنرالاته فهو
قال ايضا انه بعد انتهاء المحادثه بينهما
بساعتين عاد الى مكتب هتلر ووجد الغرفه
مليئه بالدخان واخبره الحرس الخاص ان كل
شيء قد انتهى وان جثتي هتلر وزوجته
تحترقان في الطابق العلوي من حديقه
المستشاريه رغم ان العديد من الوثائق تؤكد
انتحار هتلر الا ان الروايات الرافضه لقصه
الانتحار تتردد بين حين واخر وتلقى رواجا
واسعا حتى بعد وفاته بثمانيه وسبعين عاما
شاركونا ارائكم اي الروايات تصدقون انتحار
هتلر ام تمكنه من الهروب